هاي الذكاء الاصطناعي ويا طلابه الذكاء
الاصطناعي وش سوى فينا في الاصطناعي
الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يتسبب بالمصائب هذا
ما حدث بالضبط مع احد اعرق صحف ايرلندا
صحيفه دائري الصحيفه مشاهدينا تورطت في
مقال اكتشف عدم صحته بعد ايام يتعلق بهوس
النساء الايرلنديات
بالسمره المزيفه هذه الورطه دفعت الصحيفه
الشهيره الى الاعتذار خصوصا وانها وضعت
اسم مسؤول رعايه صحيه لكن شنو مزيف
والمسؤول الصحي هذا كان
من خيال الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي افتعل
معلومات لا اساس لها من الصحه ليؤكد مسؤول
الصحيفه انهم تورطوا في خدمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي ينتهي الامر بحذف المقال الكاذب
بعد البلبله التي احدثها الحمد لله
ضمنا موقعنا
راح يصير مذيع ما راح ولا راح يصير صحفي
يعني
احنا ليسنا في مامن اصلا لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات